madame la
Présidente la séance est ouverte le
compte-rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué y y a-t-il des
observation je n'en vois pas le
procèsverbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
mes chers collègues l'utre du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de loi adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée visant à améliorer l'accès aux
soins par l'engagement territorial des
professionnels dans la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau ministre de la santé
et de la prévention monsieur le
ministre
madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous savons que pour que notre
système de de santé soit le plus juste
et le plus efficace possible il doit
pouvoir so s'appuyer sur trois principes
fondamentaux une solidarité sans faille
celle qui soutend tout notre modèle de
protection sociale une capacité
d'adaptation et de modernisation dont
l'importance n'a jamais été aussi
visible sans doute que pendant la crise
sanitaire mais qui ne l'est pas moins
face au défis qui se dessine et un
ensemble de coopération et de lien de
confiance renforcé entre les différents
professionnels et acteurs du système
pour répondre aux besoins et aux
attentees des Français dans chacun de
nos
territoires la réponse à apportter prend
forme dans la cohérence et la
complémentarité de nos actions et des
différentes politiques menées quand on
prend les reennes du ministère de la
santé et de la prévention on est à la
fois le ministre des soins hospitaliers
comme des soins de ville de l'hôpital
public comme de l'hospitalisation privée
de ceux qui exercent en ville comme ceux
qui exercent en milieu rural et à cet
égard je voudrais le dire tout de suite
je mesure la difficulté de la tâche à
laquelle vous avez été contraint en
devant gérer simultanément
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité
sociale dont je vais introduire les
débats dans quelques heure à l'Assemblée
nationale qui traduit dans le cadre
d'une loi financière des logiques de
transformation du système en particulier
dans le champ de la prévention de
l'accès au produits de santé ou de
l'évolution du cadre de rémunération des
établissements de santé mais à devoir
faire face aussi à une proposition de
loi qui permet d'avancer sur les
dynamiques de confiance et de
responsabilité territoriale des
professionnels de santé madame la
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
madame la rapporteur générale de la
commission monsieur le Président de la
Commission ont regretté cet examen
simultané et je dois dire que je suis
sensible à leur critique peut-être
aurais-je dû défendre notre calendrier
d'examen par le Sénat de la proposition
de loi qui vous est soumise aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas si cela se pratique ici
mais je vous prie d'accepter mes excuses
je souhaitais que soit exposés
simultanément les différents éléments
qui sont aujourd'hui sur la table et je
pourrais ajouter par exemple le travail
que nous conduisons sur la convention
médicale mais je mesure que quelques
semaines après le renouvellement
sénatorial et la constitution de la
commission cela n'a pas permis sans
doute d'approfondir autant que vous
l'auriez souhaité les débats et je
souhaitais commencer par
cela mais nous sommes je pense tous
d'accord pour qu'on considérer que les
défis à relever sont à la fois immenses
et urgents et nécessitent de la
transparence c'était aussi pour cette
raison que j'avais souhaité mener de
front peut-être est-ce une erreur encore
une fois ces différents chantiers la
santé c'est en effet le premier sujet de
nos compatriotes il nous le rappelle
sans cesse vous-même et vous avez été
plusieurs à me le dire en particulier
tous ceux qui ont remis leur mandat en
jeu lors du dernier scrutin les Français
nous me le rappell aussi dans les
différents déplacements que je peux
faire il nous interpelle à raison sur le
manque de médecins et de professionnels
de santé sur les nombreux défis auxquels
notre système doit faire face autant
autant de défis que je crois pouvoir
relever je crois que nous pouvons les
relever en renforçant la confiance la
confiance des professionnels qui ont
choisi des métiers exceptionnels mais
difficile et exigeant la confiance de
nos concitoyens dans les politiques de
santé qui les protègent la confiance
dans l'avenir du système de santé et
dans ces acteurs que nous devons
coconstruire la proposition de loi
présentée à l'Assemblée nationale par
Frédéric Valtou et que vous examinez à
partir d'aujourd'hui comporte je le
pense une partie des solutions les idées
et la la matrice de l'engagement
territorial qui en est le conducteur
recouvre la volonté de mobiliser tous
les acteurs d'un territoire et de les
impliquer plus largement pour mieux
répondre à la question de l'accès aux
soins et je pense que sur ces bancs
beaucoup d'entre vous ont eu à pratiquer
concrètement dans leurs communes ou dans
leur département cet esprit de coalition
j'ai confiance pour ma part dans le sens
des responsabilités des professionnels
et je l'oppose je dois le dire tout de
suite à la à la volonté d'imposer des
mesures de coohersition notamment pour
empêcher les médecins de s'installer à
tel ou tel endroit si cela peut sembler
un remède attractif à court terme créer
des rigidités et des contraintes serait
je le crois après avoir beaucoup hésité
moi aussi sur cette question serait
contre-productif et ne ferait que
détourner encore plus de l'exercice de
la de la médecine et en particulier de
la médecine générale dont nous savons
qu'elle constitue un pilier
incontournable de l'accès à la santé de
nos concitoyens
c'est pour c'est pourquoi je souhaite
d'entrer poser un préalable important à
nos débats pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambigué ce texte n'a en aucun cas
vocation à se substituer à une action
résolue et de long terme permettant
d'augmenter structurellement le nombre
de soignants nous faisons face à une
crise démographique qui touche notre
ressource médical et soignante comme
tout les grands pays et pas seulement en
Europe c'est un fait nous avons mesuré
les dégâts du numérus closus et nous
voyons d'ors et déjà les premiers
prolégomèes des effets de sa suppression
nous formons plus de professionnel plus
15 % par an en moyenne nous
maintiendrons collectivement et
résolument notre effort je pense
notamment à ce que nous faisons avec les
régions pour former plus d'infirmiers et
d'aides
soignants tous les nouveaux
professionnels qui arriveront dans le
système bénéficieront de ces nouvelles
coopérations et de ces organisations
rénovées dans leur exercice quotidien
dont nous devons et dont nous allons
discuter mais augmenter structurellement
le nombre de professionnels tout en
portant des mesurees d'application
immédiate visant à toujours mieux
coordonner mieux répartir les
compétences de chacun en fonction des
besoins sont là deux éléments
nécessairement
complémentaires je m'y attache aussi à
mon niveau avec la reprise de la
négociation conventionnelle avec les
médecins libéraux j'accorde la plus
grande importance à cette étape
fondamentale de la relation entre la
puissance publique et la profession
c'est par la confiance et le dialogue
j'en suis convaincu que nous que nous
aboutirons à une nouvelle convention je
souhaite qu'elle puisse donner au
médecins tous les moyens pour réinventer
leur métier être davantage associés aux
évolutions du système de santé et ainsi
toujours mieux répondre aux besoins de
santé de nos
concitoyens Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur l'articulation entre ces deux
échéances d'un côté la discussion avec
les médecins libéraux de l'autre
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
adoptée vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente par l'Assemblée nationale en
juin dernier et je crois une opportunité
à saisir il s'agit de tracer la
perspective d'un Pact renouvelé de
confiance et d'engagement avec les
professionnels de santé car pour
continuer à transformer et fluidifier le
fonctionnement et l'organisation
territoriale de notre système de santé
il n'y a pas de solution miracle il n'y
a pas de solution unique ce texte
s'attache avant tout à renforcer et
donner corps à cette solidarité entre
les différentes composantes du système
de santé dans une coopération renforcée
et une responsabilité partagé à tous les
niveaux je l'ai évoqué mais rien ne
serait pire que de lier dans la loi les
mains des acteurs de santé les les
empêchant d'avoir cette agilité si
essentielle face au défis que nous
connaissons en effet si l'État doit
rester le garant des valeurs qui fondent
notre système etce que c'est bien au
niveau national que doivent être définis
les grandes priorités l'enjeu est
aujourd'hui de donner des outils et des
leviers puis de faire confiance à ceux
dans les mains desquels nous les plaçons
pour s'organiser et faciliter
l'émergence de réponsse
territorialisé ces leviers sont de
différentes nature les communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
sont aujourd'hui le cadre principal de
structuration des soins de proximité la
commission des affaires sociales a fait
le choix de supprimer le rattachement
automatique de tout professionnel de
santé à une CPTs sauf opposition de
celui-ci sans en faire un totem et le
gouvernement n'a pas présenter
d'amendements de rétablissement je pense
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
nous devrons travailler dans la navette
parlementaire une disposition qui
permettent de mieux valoriser la place
opérationnelle des CPTs les
professionnels y sont engagés les
professionnels qui sont engagés pardon
sont en effet animés de la volonté de
faire progresser les organisations
locales et il est un des que leur
mobilisation et leur enthousiasme
contribuent grandement à ce au succès de
ce type d'organisation il y avait 450
CPTs en
2019 756 en 2022 et nous venons de
franchir la barre des 80 % de la
population du pays qui est couverte par
une organisation de ce type je ne dis
pas évidemment que toutes les CPTs sont
des organisations de coordination au
même niveau de maturité mais je
considère que la dynamique à l'œuvre
montre que ces communautés répondent à
un besoin cela était déjà
particulièrement visible pendant la
crise sanitaire au cours de laquel elles
avaient facilité la mobilisation des
libéraux elles avaient fait aussi tomber
quelques murs entre professions de santé
elles sont également un lieu
d'innovation et de progrès avec par
exemple des
expérimentations permettant l'accès
direct à à certaines profession dans
leur cadre depuis des années le
gouvernement accompagne fortement ce
mouvement de structuration et je tiens à
souligner l'engagement de la ministre
déléguée Agnès firmain lebaudau qui
porte le plan 100 % CPTs et qui a
réalisé un tour de France de ces CPTs
qui a permis de dresser un état des
lieux de ces communautés dans les
territoire et d'identifier les facteurs
de succès l'intégration des
professionnels de la médecine scolaire
par exemple dans les CPTs contribue par
exemple à la coordination des
interventions des professionnels de la
santé de l'enfant c'est aussi une action
essentielle dans notre plan de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire
parallèlement à ce sujet des CPTs que
nous n'évoquerons donc qu'en creux
aujourd'hui le conseil territorial de
santé organe de démocratie sanitaire à
l'échelle du territoire et précisé dans
sa définition élargi dans sa composition
renforcé dans ses missions et ses
responsabilités pour lui permettre de
répondre aux objectifs en en matière
d'amélioration de l'accès et de é des
soins les députés comme vous-même vous
êtes largement saisis de cette mesure si
j'accueille favorablement l'ajout de la
participation de des conseils des ordres
professionnels le gouvernement défendra
sur ce point une proposition de
compromis entre les versions travaillé
dans les deux assemblées rétablissant
notamment les leviers d'action à la main
des acteurs territoriaux pour créer une
offre de santé dans les territoires où
elle est insuffisante en première
intention ce texte confie ainsi aux
professionnels de santé qui siègent dans
les et cts la responsabilité collective
de s'organiser afin de répondre aux
besoins identifiés dans leur
territoire le texte et c'est un point
sur lequel je voudrais insister nous
avons déjà échangé évidemment avec la
rapporteur ou le président de la
Commission le texte propose en outre
d'élargir la responsabilité collective
d'organisation de la permanence des
soins en établissement de santé la
fameuse pdses qui revient aux
établissements et aux professionnels de
santé qui les composent dans le public
comme dans le privé il s'agit de mettre
en œuvre cette responsabilité collective
et notamment de rééquilibrer le
dispositif entre le secteur public et le
secteur privé pour réduire la pression
sur l'hôpital là encore ce point a pu
faire l'objet de nombreux débats sur les
modalités le gouvernement a proposé une
position que j'estime équilibrée et
réaliste construite avec les acteurs et
clarifiant ce nouveau cadre de
participation des établissements de
santé et des professionnels de santé y
exerçant ce nouveau cadre traduit à la
fois la confiance faite aux acteurs des
territoires pour s'organiser puisqu'il
repose en premier lieu sur un appel à
candidature des établissements qui
seront libres d'y répondre pour les
établissements publics ou privés non
lucratifs comme pour les cliniques
privées avec l'accord des praticiens
libéraux qui exercent aussi lorsqu'un
établissement participant à la pdses ne
pourra pas assumer sa mission faute de
personnel suffisant et seulement après
ce premier appel à candidature le
directeur général de l'ARS pourra
intervenir afin de permettre à
l'établissement d'assurer la permanence
des soins qui lui incombe je tiens à
insister sur ce point qui me paraît
crucial le principe du volontariat et de
la confiance dans les établissements et
dans les professionnels de santé
exerçant en leur sein est un pilier de
cette future organisation de la pdses ça
n'est que de façon ultime et subsidiaire
en cas de carence et en dernier recours
qu'un établissement et ses
professionnels de santé pourront être
désignés pour assurer cette mission dont
l'exercice sera exclusivement effectué
dans les dans l'établissement sollicité
les professionnels de santé salariés des
établissements publics ou libéraux
pourront par ailleurs être sollicités
pour venir renforcer les équipes
d'autres établissement mais et je
soulligne là aussi ce point uniquement
s'ils se sont portés volontaires pour le
faire outre les dispositifs structurants
que sont donc les cts l'organisation de
la pdses et je l'appelle de mes vœux la
continuité de la structuration des CPTs
le texte comporte plusieurs avancées
portant sur des points plus précis et je
vais aller rapidement pour en citer
certains nous aurons lors des débats
tout le loisir de les
approfondir ce texte prévoit ainsi de
consolider le lien essenel entre les
patients et leurs professionnels de
santé habituelle pour éviter des
ruptures dans les parcours de soins je
pense par exemple à la création de la
fonction d'infirmier référent qui prend
tout son sens au service des patients en
affection de longue durée comme le
traduit l'apport fait par la commission
des affaires sociales sans oublier les
mesures concernant le statut et la
gouvernance des hôpitaux ainsi que les
dispositions spécifiqu applicable aux
praticiens étrangers diplômés hors de
l'Union Européenne ou relative aux
outrmè et je salue à ce titre le travail
important qui a été conduit par agès
firmain lebaudau sur ces sujets je
prends tout de même quelques instant
pour revenir sur une mesure importante
celle portant sur l'interdiction de
l'intérim en début de carrière soignante
je voudrais en effet revenir sur un
point les différentes mesures mises en
place pour mieux réguler l'intérim ne
visent pas cette pratique en soi mais
les excès qui ont pu y être associés
c'est tout le sens du plafonnement de la
mise en application du plafonnement des
montants des rémunérations des
praticiens intérimaires mené par mon
prédécesseur François Bron au printemps
dernier en application de la loi du 26
avril 2021 visant à améliorer le système
de santé je voulais citer le nom de
François Bron car cette mesure sur les
limitations de l'excès de l'intérim est
une mesure difficile que à plusieurs
reprises dans des gouvernements
différents il a été à laquelle il a été
finalement exclu de recourir et je pense
qu'elle était pour autant nécessaire
même si à court terme et je le mesure
dans certains établissements elle pose
encore des difficultés la possibilité de
pouvoir recourir à l'intérim est
nécessaire en effet dans le système de
santé c'est contre le dévoiement de ce
qui doit rester à la fois une soupape et
une capacité d'ouverture que le
gouvernement sur la base d'une
proposition de loi a souhaité renforcer
sa mobilisation car l'intérim ne
peut-être le mode de fonctionnement
habituel ni pour les établissements ni
pour les professionnels il nous faut
trouver l'équilibre permettant de
stabiliser et de renforcer les
collectifs de travail hospitalier mais
aussi de mieux accompagner les jeunes
soignants dans le passage du statut
d'étudiant à celui de professionnels de
santé en leur permettant de continuer à
développer leur leurs connaissances dans
des collectifs stables c'est aussi dans
cette optique d'attractivité et de
construction de collectif que le
gouvernement a présenté par amendement
une une mesure d'équité une mesure qui
vise à remettre en cause une injustice
qui pèse aujourd'hui sur la
l'attractivité des carrière hospitalo
universitaire en proposant de traiter
désormais à l'identique les les
émoluments hospitaliers et les émolument
universitaire mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs j'ai confiance
dans notre capacité à trouver des
solutions aux difficultés avec comme
pierre angulaire pierre angulaire une
meilleure organisation territoriale des
soins par la confiance donnée aux
acteurs de terrain pour susciter leur
engagement encourager leur meilleure
coordination et renforcer leur
responsabilités je l'ai dit d'entré ce
texte s'inscrit dans un chantier plus
large celui de notre action résolue au
service de nos concitoyens et des
professionnels de santé et je souhaite
que nous continuions à avancer ensemble
je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est désormais à notre collègue
madame corineber rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues la session parlementaire
débute à peine que nous sommes déjà
chargés d'examiner un nouveau texte sur
l'accès aux soins si la récurrence de
l'exercice montre les attentes de nos
concitoyens sur le sujet force de
constater qu'elle révèle également
l'incapacité des pouvoirs publics à
trouver des solutions adaptées à
l'ampleur de la crise que traverse notre
système de
santé face à cela nous ne pouvons que
déplorer deux erreurs manifestes du
gouvernement la première tient à la
méthode depuis plusieurs années
maintenant aucun projet de loi
c'est-à-dire rappelons-le un projet
assorti d'une étude d'impact et d'un
avis du Conseil d'État n'a été déposé
concernant l'organisation des soins dans
notre pays le gouvernement a privilégié
des mesures épars en loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale avec leur lot de
cavaliers sociaux censurés et des
propositions de loi de sa majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale le résultat est là
aucune cohérence d'ensemble pour une
politique de santé pourtant érigée en
priorité par l'exécutif
pire
pire une série de mesures mal calibrées
nonont eu de cesse de crisper des
acteurs pourtant déjà
éprouvé la seconde erreur tient au
calendrier elle est double et vous
l'avez reconnu monsieur le le ministre
erreur de calendrier car le débat
parlementaire intervient encore comme
pour la loiriste 2 en parallèle des
négociations conventionnelles que mène
l'assurance maladie avec les médecins
erreur de calendrier encore en nous
contraignant à examiner cette
proposition de loi en parallèle du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale malgré l'opposition
plusieurs fois manifestée par la
commission j'accepte vos excuses
monsieur le ministre ce ce contexte
étant posé et ce regret formulé j'envens
aux disposition de cette proposition de
loi passée lors de son examen à
l'Assemblée nationale de 11 à 39
articles j'ai pu le déplorer en
commission ce texte se présente comme un
patchwork mal tissé et dont les pièces
produisent ensemble un résultat parfois
hasardeux face à cela la Commission a
choisi de retenir les mesures qui lui
paraissaient effectivement utiles aux
patients comme aux soignants et
d'écarter sans retenue excessive les
dispositions cosmétiques parfois
bavardes et sans porté en d'autres mots
nous avons fait un peu de ménage
concernant l'organisation des soins de
ville ce texte n'apporte malheureusement
pas de ligne directrices clair plusieurs
articles sans effet réel agissant
agissait inutilement au repoussoir pour
les professionnels de santé la
Commission les a rejeté en supprimant
l'automatisation de l'adhésion des
professionnels de santé aux communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
tout comme la réécriture des
dispositions relatives à la permanence
de soins adopté en mai dernier et qui
n'ont même pas encore produit tous leurs
effets de la même manière la commission
écartait la création superflu d'un
nouvel indicateur territorial de l'offre
de soins jugé pu peu utile par les les
auteurs
eux-mêmes la Commission en revanche
soutenu les dispositions portant des
mesures de bon sens après les arouis
parfois sensiblement amendé j'en veux
pour preuve l'article 1er relative à la
démocratie en santé les territoires de
démocratie sanitaire renommé territoire
de santé pourront être redéfinis par les
acteurs locaux et c'est là le principal
apport de cet article qui ne confi en
réalité aucun nouveau moyen d'action au
conseil territorial de santé la
Commission a resserré une rédaction
inutilement bavarde dont on peenait à
saisir la cohérence globale la
commission également adopter le principe
d'une obligation faite aux
professionnels médicaux de déclarer en
amont la cessation de leur activité dans
un territoire après avoir amené le délai
prévu à 3 mois elle a en outre préservé
l'accompagnement de l'expérimentation
des antennes officine dans les petites
communes s'agissant de la prise en
charge médicale des résidents dans les
éepades la Commission a soutenu la
revalorisation du rôle du médecin
coordonnateur et repousser la
désignation de ce praticien comme
médecin traitant qui apparaît trop
risqué à ce stade enfin la Commission a
également adopté la création de la
fonction d'infirmier référent jugeant
qu'il s'agissait d'une reconnaissance
importante du rôle des infirmiers dans
la coordination et le suivi des
patients vous le voyez mes chers
collègues ce texte se fera œuvre utile
sans apporter pour autant de réponse
miracle aux difficultés que nous
connaissons est-ce à dire pour autant
qu'il faillant faire le véhicule de
disposition choc et engager ici la
régulation de l'installation des
médecins j'entends les pressions de
certains mais je ne le crois pas dans un
contexte marqué par des difficultés
démographiques et des tensions
importantes apparues lors de la
négociation de la prochaine convention
médicale la régulation de l'installation
ne pourrait s'apparenter qu'un signe de
défiance à l'égard de la profession elle
ne ferait qu'aggraver des difficultés en
décourageant les médecins à
s'installer au contraire la Commission
fait le choix de mesures pragmatique en
s'efforçant d'actionner les bons leviers
identifiés par les professionnels
eux-mêmes c'est le cas notamment des
mesures visantes à libérer du temps
médical en accompagnant les médecins
dans leur démarche avec le développement
des guichets uniques départementaux ou
en limitant les actes superflus nous y
reviendrons en séance avec le même
objectif la Commission a soutenu le
recul à 75 ans de l'âge limite
d'exercice pour les médecins qui étaient
soumis tandis qu'elle a levé des freins
à l'exercice coordonné elle a en outre
adopté certaines mesures irritantes mais
utile comme la limitation à une fois
tous les 10 ans de l'octroit des aides à
l'installation enfin la Commission a
soutenu les dispositions qui visaient à
permettre à davantage de praticiens
étrangers d'exercer en France elle vous
proposera d'adopter un amendement
permettant leur exercice en ambulatoire
dans la période de consolidation des
compétences précédant l'autorisation de
plein exercice si il s'agit là encore
d'une manière pragmatique d'améliorer
l'accès aux soins dans les années
difficiles qui
s'annoncent malgré un Big Bang annoncé
par le président de la République lors
de ses vœux ce texte ne traduit pas non
plus de changement radical pour les
établissements de santé la proposition
de loi entend modifier différents aspect
d'organisation de gouvernance de
l'hôpital public que la Commission a
souhaité accompagner elle a ainsi
précisé et sécurisé les avancées
concernant l'ouverture d'un droit
d'option pour l'octroit de la
personnalité morale au groupement
hospitaliers de territoire ou encore
concernant la composition et les
missions du conseil de
surveillance surtout la Commission a
partagé le souci d'un rééquilibrage de
l'effort en matière de permanence des
soins en établissement de santé quand en
permettre l'article 4 c'est un sujet
important pour garantir la bonne prise
en charge des patients nécessitant des
soins à l'issue de leur passage aux
urgences c'est aussi une nécessité qu'en
gardes et astreintes apparaissent
aujourd'hui parfois comme une raison de
la fuite des praticiens de l'hôpital
public sur cet article je regrette que
les tentative de discussion avec le
gouvernement mené avant la séance n'est
pu aboutir nous trouverons aujourd'hui
je l'espère une rédaction efficace
claire et répondant au préoccupations
des établissements et des praticiens
d'une part et au besoins des patients
d'autre
part toujours sur ce volet refond
surface certaines dispositions censurées
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale 2023 je pense ici à
l'accompagnement de la réforme des
autorisations d'activités de soins mais
aussi à l'encadrement de l'intérim en
établissement de santé et
médicau-sociaux ou contrôle des
cliniques privées la Commission est
restée fidèle au position qu'elle avait
porté à l'automne dernier sur le sujet
particulier de l'intérim alors que le
gouvernement justifie la mesure par une
nécessité liée à la sécurité des soins
la Commission a estimé que le sujet
n'était pas uniquement celui du début de
carrière elle a ainsi prévu un
plafonnement au cours de la carrière
soit simplement l'interdiction d'un
exercice exclusif par le biais de
contrat mise à disposition s'agissant
enfin des études de santé la Commission
a renforcé la respons stabilisation de
tous les acteurs de la formation des
étudiants en santé qui apparaît
indispensable face à la dégradation de
la santé mentale de ces professionnels
en devenenir nous avons également
soutenu les dispositions étendant le
contrat d'engagement de service public
aux étudiants de pharmacie et de
maillotique mes chers collègues vous
l'avez aisément compris la commission
examiné ce texte sans un enthousiasme
excessif pour autant sur la base des
larges modification qu'elle a apporté la
semaine passée et sous réserve de
nouveaux ajustements qu'elle soutiendra
aujourd'hui la commission vous demandera
d'adopter ce texte et les avancées qu'il
contient espérons néanmoins madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous retrouver dans
quelques mois avec cette fois un texte
porteur d'une ambition à la hauteur des
défis auxquels est confronté notre
système de santé nous n'assurerons pas
un juste accès aux soins dans les
territoires par des improvisations
menées contre les médecins et nous ne
répondrons pas à la crise de sens des
professionnels hospitaliers par des
mesurettes même récurrentes je vous
remercie merci Madame la rapporteur dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Nadia sologou pour
le groupe UC pour 4
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues presque
tous les patients de France ont des
difficultés désormais pour accéder aux
soins dans ce contexte Frédéric Valtou
propose un certain nombre de mesures il
a au moins le mérite d'essayer dire que
la situation pourrait s'améliorer par je
cite l'engagement territorial des
professionnels pourrai pourtant blesser
ceux qui sans relâche s'engagent dans
leur territoire tout comme leurs
patients ils subissent les effets
déléire d'une démographie médicale et
paramédicale dont ils ne sont pas
responsables le seul et unique sujet
c'est le déséquilibre entre l'offre de
temps soignant et les besoins de notre
population par ailleurs vieillissante
rien ne sera réglé tant que l'on
n'intégrera pas que les jeunes médecins
donnent en moyenne deux fois moins de
temps médical que leurs aînés rien ne
sera réglé tant que les étudiants en
santé serviront pendant leurs études de
main d'œuvre bon marché dans un système
en tension chronique rien ne sera réglé
tant que nos soignants renonceront après
seulement quelques années d'exercice
parfois même en cours
d'étude rien ne sera réglé tant que les
jeunes Français partiront étudier à
l'étranger rien ne sera réglé tant que
les facultés de pharmacie seront vides
rien ne sera réglé tant que l'on se
tournera en désespoir de cause vers des
diplômés hors Union Européenne ultime
solution d'urgence siffonant ainsi la
ressource d'autres pays nos
professionnels ont beau s'engager tant
et plus rien ne se réglera hélas par ce
texte je salue cependant certaines
mesures de bon sens qui figurent ainsi
l'expérimentation des antennes
d'officine et l'encadrement des mesures
fiscale d'aide à l'installation quand
l'heure est grave ce sont toujours les
acteurs de terrain qui savent optimiser
les moyens ainsi au plus fort de la
crise covid alors que l'administration
comptable était totalement dépassée ce
sont bien les professionnels de santé
qui ont permis au système de tenir
tirons-en les leçons et méfions-nous de
toutes les fausses bonnes solutions
démagogiques une infirmière me disait
récemment les CPTs obligatoire mais
pourquoi travailler ensemble on le fait
et encore ce jeune ké les équipes
s'agrèent de façon spontanée avec une
belle dynamique elle mène un combat
pluriprofessionnel il faudrait donner
les dotations aux équipes plutôt qu'aux
individus ce serait plus efficace que
d'essayer d'organiser de force des des
équipes qui n'en sont pas oui il y a un
vrai enjeu d'interprofessionnalité et il
ne faut pas le compromettre avec des
mesures descendantes si les patients
demandent plus de temps médical les
soignants en demande également en
voulant structurer autoritairement leur
exercice on risque d'alourdir leur
charge administrative la grande
gaspilleuse de temps médical de même en
les projetant sur les routes pour des
présences physiques exigées ici et là on
consomme en transport une ressource
pourtant si précieuse la pression
générale que l'on fait peser sur les
médecins en particulier amène à des
incohérences ainsi l'un d'eux me disait
quand un libéral ne travaille que 35 he
c'est un salot alors que quand un
salarié arrive dans un centre de santé
pour y travailler 35 heures on
l'accueille en héros il ne faut ni
attiser les corporatismes ni dresser les
professionnels les un contre les autres
mais encourager un dynamisme collectif
qui émerge comme la seule piste
vertueuse
je salue la part que donne ce texte à la
formation il faut en priorité absolue
augmenter les capacités de formation
pour les faire converger avec les
besoins des territoires je souhaite
également rappeler que dans la situation
grave que nous connaissons les
directeurs d'Ars doivent pouvoir
utiliser réellement quand le besoin
impérieux s'en fait sentir le pouvoir de
dérogation que leur donne la loi
certaines pénuries et je pense par
exemple au manque de pharmaciens
hospitaliers dans la Nièvre doivent dans
le seul intérêt des patients permettre
de mettre en place des solutions qui
sont réellement vitales pour conclure je
souhaite confirmer le soutien d'une
majorité du groupe centriste un texte
modifié en commission nous devons nous
méfier de la communication qui ne serait
plus que négative ne pas ériger en règle
les injonctions aux professionnels de
santé leur dire que nos débats ne
doivent pas se limiter à des
négociations conventionnel peut-être
leur redire notre confiance pour passer
ensemble un cap bien difficile je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame sologou
la parole est désormais à Madame Anne
Souiris pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire pour 5
minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de commission madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues comme
vous en êtes tous et tout conscient
comme monsieur le ministre l'a répété en
début de séance je pense aussi
particulièrement à la période que nous
avons pu vivre le drame du covid ces
dernières années où vous étiez directeur
de l'agence régionale de santé il y a
urgence pour la santé dans notre pays
c'est une urgence qui ne peut se
résoudre que part trois moyens une
formation accru des soignants une
meilleure régulation et une gouvernance
sanitaire beaucoup plus
décentralisée démocratique donc réactive
et efficace les fragilités en santé de
nos territoires se multiplient face aux
effets du changement climatique de la 6e
extinction de masse et de la popul et de
la pollution massive de nos
environnements les canicules ravagent
notre pays en 2022 la France
enregistrait un excès de de mortalité du
aux canicules de plus de 2800 personnes
plus qu'en
2003 les épidémies de zoonose nous
guettent avec la colonisation des
moustiques tigres et leur transmission
de maladies les pollutions de l'air des
sols de l'eau et même de la cathédrale
Notre-Dame de Paris qui verra bientôt
400 tonnes de plombs s'abattre à nouveau
sur elle cause perturbation
endocrinienne cancer maladies
neurodégénérativ et est mort soyons
lucid nous ne sommes pas préparés pour
affronter un monde à 50 degrés soyons
lucides encore la démocratie en santé
cruciale pour affronter les épidémies ne
guide toujours pas les politiques
gouvernementales comme l'ont
tragiquement rappelé le covid-19 et la
variole
simienne trop de personnes sont encore
excluses des décisions prises concernant
leur propre santé les plus des plus
précaires aux jeunes migrants isolés en
passant par les personnes dépendantes
aux drogues les travailleuses et les
travailleurs du sexe tous ceux et celles
dans dont on détourne si facilement les
yeux cela fait plus de 40 ans que le VIH
SIDA Séville et les pouvoirs publics
n'ont toujours pas pris conscience des
leç de cette maladie qui a décimé et
déciim encore les plus discriminés
d'entre nous malgré l'immense engagement
des associations de lutte contre le sida
pour obliger l'État à une prise de
conscience nous ne sommes toujours pas
préparés à affronter les prochaines
épidémies enfin alors que la population
française vieillit le nombre de
soignantes et de soignants diminue
résultat de 40 années d'austérité et
d'impréparation partout en France et
même à Paris les soins deviennent
inaccessibles et encore plus dans les
territoires ruraux et pour les plus
précaires pour qui un seul pour qui seul
le recours à des professionnels
conventionnés en secteur 1 est une
option 52 jours en moyenne pour obtenir
un rendez-vous d'ophtalmologie 61 pour
la dermatologie plus d'un quart des
médecins généralistes à plus de 60 ans
disons-le clairement sans changement
majeur les années qui viennent s'annonc
extrêmement difficile que faire nous
nous manquons d'une politique écologiste
de santé qui construisent des solutions
depuis les territoires qui prennent en
compte des déterminants environnementaux
de la santé les facteurs nonhains qui
fabriquent la santé en démocratie avec
toutes et tous notamment avec et pour
les plus exclus nous manquons de
réflexion profonde sur notre système de
santé et son financement nous manquons
d'une politique ambitieuse de santé
environnementale et de prévention de
santé communautaire de réduction des
risques nous manquons d'un effort
national et massif pour revaloriser les
métiers du soin pour prévenir les effets
de transformation planétaire et lutter
contre les lobby écociidaires pour faire
en sorte que notre système public de
santé tienne le choc mes chers collègues
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
n'est pas à la hauteur de l'urgence
malgré ses qualités initiale en se
bornant à l'organisation des
professionnels de santé il manque son
rendez-vous avec la lutte contre la
désartification médicale et les besoins
de nos territoires cette proposition de
loi comportait pourtant quelques
dispositions qui allit dans le bon sens
la réforme de la démocratie sanitaire
locale l'élargissement des pouvoirs de
délibération des conseils de
surveillance des hôpitaux la régulation
de l'installation des médecins au fil du
circuit législatif trop de ces
dispositions ont été amoindries
aujourd'hui il nous faut trouver
ensemble la manière de transformer ce
texte pour qu'il permette de
véritablement améliorer l'accès aux
soins c'est évidemment possible mais
quittons je l'espère nous allons y
arriver des postures partisanes pour
changer la vie nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens nous en avons besoin il y a
urgence je vous en
remercie merci Madame Souiris la parole
est désormais à Madame Céline brullin
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste
kanaki pour 5
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a
quelques jours j'étais avec les salariés
de la clinique de l'abay à fécan des
agents de l'hôpital public et les
habitants mobilisés pour que la clinique
en redressement judiciaire soit reprise
avec l'ensemble de ses salariés par
l'hôpital public à défaut un service de
chirurgie disparaîtrait entraînant
d'autres graves conséquences pour les
FEAMP poid le devenir de la maternité y
étant lié par exemple je sollicite
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre toute
votre attention sur cette situation à
travers cela je veux redire ici ce que
subissent des millions de nos citoyen
fermeture des urgences récurrentes délai
de rendez-vous excessif pour consulter
un généraliste impossibilité de trouver
un spécialiste parfois comment accepter
que 6 millions de personnes n'aient pas
de médecin dans notre pays que la
mortalité infantile progresse et que nos
urgences pédiatriques soient au bord de
l'effondrement comment ne pas comprendre
que de plus en plus de nos concitoyens
se sentent abandonnés par la République
les professionnels de santé en ville
comme à l'hôpital sont eux-mêmes épuisés
l'un d'entre eux nous disait lors des
auditions que vous avez organisé madame
la rapporteur ne même pas voir le début
de la lumière au bout du tunnel cette
situation nécessiterait un plan Marchal
un projet de loi ambitieux des mesures
structurelles et des moyens à la hauteur
de l'enjeu en guise de quoi nous avons
cette proposition de loi qui intervient
quelques mois seulement après la
proposition de loi Rist quelques jours
avant l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
alors que se réouvr des négociations
conventionnelles avec les médecins un
texte fait de mesures d'affichage
technocratique pour certaines dont on
peut douter des effets réels sur
l'amélioration de l'offre de soins une
proposition de loi qui dès son titre
semble vouloir faire peser sur les
seules professions de santé la situation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
exonérant l'état la puissance publique
en général de ses propres propre
responsabilité et qui considère la
territorialisation comme réponse absolue
mais donnez tous les pouvoirs que vous
voulez au Conseil territoriaux de santé
s'ils doivent continuer de gérer pardon
la pénurie de soignants ils ne
parviendront pas à améliorer l'accès aux
soins or c'est précisément ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens comme les
élus locaux les collectivités locales
qui se démène pour améliorer les choses
mais se heurent à des travers
structurels de notre système de santé
alors certes cette proposition de loi
contient de C de là quelques mesures
intéressantes par exemple l'encadrement
de l'intérim le retour à une forme de
solidarité du secteur privé pour
rétablir la permanence des soins ou
encore l'exonération de la majoration du
ticket modérateur pour les patients dont
le médecin part en retraite sans être
remplacé mais ce texte manque
cruellement d'ambition et les
modifications de la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat en limitent
encore la portée je pense notamment à la
permanence des soins ambulatoires sujet
crucial à nos yeux la Commission a
également atténué le principe de
responsabilité collective des
établissements publics et privés sur la
permanence des soins en introduisant un
principe de gradation du processus pas
de quoi donc changer véritablement la
donne trop peu également sur la
formation pour engager un réel effort de
formation il faudrait partir des besoins
et pas des limites capacitaires de nos
université notamment il faudrait
démocratiser les études de santé
s'appuyer sur ceux qui veulent devenir
infirmiers et que parcours sup écarte
trop souvent des ifs si peu encore en
faveur de la régulation de
l'installation des médecins seul
professionnel de santé à ne pas y être
soumis alors que l'échec de la liberté
d'installation est aujourd'hui avéré
enfin ce texte ne répond pas à l'indigne
situation faite au praticiens à diplôme
hors Union Européenne les pas
qui forme les premières lignes dans les
services des hôpitaux désertés avec une
rémunération bien inférieure aux
responsabilités qu'ils exercent en
supprimant des articles en les renvoyant
au débat du projet de loi sur
l'immigration la majorité sénatoriale
fait le choix de débattre des conditions
de séjour des Pasu par le prisme du
contrôle de l'immigration plutôt que par
celui de l'accès aux soins voilà
pourtant bien la véritable priorité de
nos concitoyens notre groupe a déposé
une trentaine d'amendements pour par
exemple rétablir l'obligation de garde
les soirs et les weekends pour encadrer
l'installation des médecins permettre
aux collectivités territoriales de
bénéficier des aides à l'installation
pour par exemple la création de centres
de santé et globalement pour
véritablement favoriser l'accès aux
soins de tous parce que non tout n'a pas
été essayé pour faire face à la
désertification médicale que nous
connaissons et qu'il faut d'urgence
sortir des impasses de notre système de
santé je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame Brulin la parole est à Madame
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 5 minutes madame
guillotinés monsieur le madame la
Présidente pardon monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente de monsieur le
président de commission ça démarre mal
madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues face à la crise sans précédent
que traverse notre système de santé le
législateur n'a de cesse de multiplier
les lois et pourtant forcé de constater
que l'accès aux soins se dégrade cette
1e proposition de loi qui ne parvient
toujours pas à convaincre elle
intervient dans un contexte de
négociation difficile à peine 6 mois
après l'adoption de la loi riste qui a
déjà soulevé de nombreuses contestations
et
crispation nous devons je crois à nos
concitoyens un discours de vérité la
situation ne va pas s'améliorer tout de
suite
nous avons devant nous plusieurs années
difficiles avant les premiers effets du
desserrement du numeris closus dans
cette attente parce que nous avons
besoin d'attirer les futurs praticiens
parce que nous avons besoin de préserver
ce qui reste il est indispensable
d'envoyer des signaux positifs aux
professionnels de santé cette PPL ne
parvient pas à le faire alors même que
des filières indispensables comme la
psychiatrie la gériatrie la santé
publique sont loin d'avoir rempli leurs
effectifs cette année la médecine
générale quant à elle occupe désormais
la 42e place sur 44 parmi les
préférences des internes signal
inquiétant si la tendance s'accentue
alors que tous demande un choc de
simplification l'article 1 tente de
ranimer les conseils territoriaux de
santé qui sont restés des coquivides
depuis leur création notre organisation
territoriale il faut l'admettre est
complexe avec de nombreuses
organisations qui coexistent et se
superposent CLS CPTs MSP ESP DAC cts
réseau villehôpital ghchté je crois que
j'en oublie pas mal si la
décentralisation par contre et le
renforcement de la démocratie sanitaire
sont essentiells et je suis très ferme
quand je le dis pour refonder notre
système de santé ils doivent
obligatoirement s'accompagner de
simplification d'une gouvernance claire
et de moyens et je crois que l'article 1
reste au milieu du gay j'en viens
maintenant à l'article 3 le plus
irritant de ce texte je soutiens sa
suppression par la rapporteur j'ai bien
compris qu'il s'agissait d'une
inscription automatique mais non
obligatoire sur le modèle de la liste
électorale mais le plus simple et le
plus efficace reste l'adhésion sur le
volontariat les CPTs sont jeunes
laissons les outils aux mains des
acteurs de santé et de terrain
laissons-les s'organiser faisons leur
confiance comme vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre c'est une leçon de la crise
covid qui a fait preuve de son
efficacité nous ne devons pas l'oublier
j'ai toutefois certaines divergences
avec le texte issu de nos travaux en
commission je pense en effet que la mise
à disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux dans les maisons de santé
et cabinet en zone sdans limité dans le
temps sous certaines conditions peut
faciliter et encourager l'installation
de professionnel j'avais d'ailleurs
soutenu la proposition de loi de notre
collègue Danny wat bed sur le sujet je
souhaite également réintroduire la
possibilité pour les résidents des pades
de désigner un médecin coordonnateur
comme médecin traitant cette possibilité
offerte au médecin co qui le souhait
peut améliorer la prise en charge
médicale des résidents dans certaines
structures j'y ai participé à titre
professionnel et je trouvais que c'était
une bonne solution enfin concernant
l'article 10 je suis favorable à la
création de cartte de séjour pour les
praticiens diplômés hors Union
Européenne cette simplification répond à
une vraie problématique dans les
hôpitaux où ces professionnels exercent
et existent et complètent utilement les
effectifs concernant l'intérim je
conserve quelques doutes et j'attends
les débats sur les différentes
propositions j'ai voté comme beaucoup en
faveur du plafonnement des rémunération
aujourd'hui c'est sur la limitation du
mode d'exercice que nous nous penchons
si l'intérim mercenaire est à combat
s'il doit rester l'exception et non la
règle je crois que c'est surtout aux
causes qu'il faut s'attaquer et là
encore je crois que revient le débat sur
l'attractivité de nos carrières
hospitalières je souhaiterai je
soutiendrai donc toutes les mesures qui
vont dans ce sens de l'attractivité
notamment la montée en compétenence des
professionnels avec la création du
statut d'infirmier référent le guichet
unique qui doit être renforcé élargi et
attention à ce qu'il joue un rôle très
concret qu'il associe les représentants
des jeunes médecins nous avons un
amendement en ce sens la répartition de
la charge de la permanence de soins
autres hôpitaux privés et hôpitaux
publics est une mesure juste sous
réserve et je défendrai également un
amendement que les praticiens ass surent
la garde et ne puissent l'effectuer que
dans leur établissement habituel afin de
sécuriser leurs pratiques enfin les
options santé dans les lycées situé en
zone déficitaire sont une mesure sur
laquelle je travaille à la région
grandantes et je me réjouis de l'avoir
expérimenté à plus large échelle dans ce
texte elle permettra effectivement de
donner envie aux jeunes de s'engager
dans cette voie et surtout de rompre
avec le déterministme social et
géographique que l'on connaît je
concluraai comme j'ai commencé par un
appel à un choc d'attractivité attention
à ne pas décourager les derniers
fantassin qui porte notre système de
santé à coût d'inflation législative de
suradministration ou de coerciss
laissant penser que l'acteur de terrain
est le cœur du problème alors qu'il doit
en être la solution je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame verotnique
Guillotin la parole est désormais à
Madame Solange nadille pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 3
minutes et 30
[Applaudissements]
secondes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues cette proposition de loi
déposée à l'Assemblée nationale par le
député Valtou contient plusieurs mesures
visant à renforcer les instruments à
disposition des acteurs afin d'accroître
la coopération entre les professionnels
de santé dans l'objectif d'améliorer
l'accès aux soins et de répondre aux
inégalités territoriales de santé
l'accès aux soins demeure l'une des
préoccupations majeures des Français
notamment dans les outr-mers où la
densité de médecins est très inférieure
à la moyenne nationale ainsi en
Guadeloupe dans ma circonscription les
îles du sud je veux par parler de Terre
de Bas Terre de Haut la Désirade Marie
Galante souffre de l'absence totale de
médecins pour certaines ces territoires
souffrent en effet de la double
insularité et des difficultés d'accès
inhérente je suis une hienne je viens de
terredebas aujourd'hui c'est le cas de
la Désirade malgré l'ouverture de centre
de santé et la présence quelques jours
par semaine de médecin l'offre de soins
il demeure très insuffisante et la
population rencontre une forte
difficulté d'accès aux soins classé au
4e irang des régions françaises ayant
les densités de médecins généralistes
libéraux les plus faibles la Guadeloupe
est donc bien un véritable désert
médical si le problème de la qualité de
la formation reste le principal frein
sur le territoire guadeloupéen nous
misons également sur les maisons de
santé qui se développent dans les
communes pour attirer et fidéliser les
médecin la proposition de loi présentée
aujourd'hui va donc dans le bon sens
puisqu'elle permet de faire du
territoire de santé l'échelon de
référence de l'organisation locale de la
politique de santé le conseil
territorial de santé cts qui en est
l'organe de gouvernance devra définir
notamment les objectifs prioritaires en
en matière d'accès aux soins de
permanence des soins et d'équilibre
territorial de l'offre de soins de plus
pour lutter contre le Nomadis médical
les aides financières et les
exonérations fiscales à l'installation
seront limité à une fois tous les 10 ans
le texte facilite également l'exercice
des médecins étrangers appelés
praticiens diplômés hors de l'Union
Européenne pas du notre groupe proposera
par ailleurs plusieurs amendements en
permettant que le dispositif soit rendu
applicable à Mayotte et en le
prolongeant au-delà du 31 décembre 2025
de plus dans un souci de simplification
des procédures administratives une seule
commission territoriale d'autorisation
d'exercice sera constitué pour la Guyane
la Martinique la Guadeloupe Mayotte et
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon un autre
amendement a également été déposé pour
augmenter le nombre d'officines de
pharmacie à Mayotte nombre qui paraît
aujourd'hui insuffisant au regard de
l'augmentation de la population et du
développement de l'offre de soins sur
l'île et les de nouvelles mississions
confiées aux pharmaciens d'officine le
texte présenté contribuera également à
l'amélioration des conditions de
formation des futurs médecins en
étendant aux étudiants en médecine
odontologie maotique en étendant aussi
aux pharmacies dès la fin de la 2e année
du premier cycle d'études en santé le
bénéfice du contrat d'engagement de
service public en effet par
l'attribution d'une allocation mensuelle
ce contrat permettra aux étudiants de
s'engager à exercer 2 ans minimum sur un
territoire sous-doté ainsi cette
proposition de loi définit une meilleure
organisation loc de notre système de
santé avec la mise en place de mesures
incitatives qui permettront d'améliorer
le maillage territorial actuel je vous
remercie merci Madame nadille la parole
est à Madame Émilienne pouirol pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 9
minutes
merci madame madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous sommes aujourd'hui
réunis pour examiner une nouvelle
proposition de loi sur les déserts
médicaux alors que nous demandons depuis
des années une loi ambitieuse de de
réorganisation complète de notre système
de santé celle-ci ne semble toujours pas
être à l'agenda du gouvernement et nous
allons donc examiner aujourd'hui une 1è
proposition de loi sans véritable portée
et dont certains articles n'ont aucun
lien avec les désert médicaux l'accès à
la santé partout et pour tous voilà ce
qui devrait motiver l'action du
gouvernement et non pas une logique
purement comptable de réduction des
dépenses et en ce sens vous parliez tout
à l'heure monsieur le ministre du P FSS
il n'est pas de nature à nous rassurer
puisque l'ONDAM va être pour la deuxème
fois consécutive inférieure à
l'inflation et donnera pas donc des
moyens suffisants pour répondre aux
enjeux structurels d'accès aux soins
nous le voyons tous dans nos territoires
cette vision courttermiste des
politiques de santé nous mène
aujourd'hui dans une situation où
l'accès aux soins n'est plus garanti
dans notre pays et je rappelle les
chiffres 30 % de la population française
vit dans un désert médical 11 % de la
population c'est-à-dire 6 millions de
personnes n'ont pas de médecins traitant
et jaacé ce sont 1,6 millions de
personnes qui renonc aux soins
l'inquiétude monte donc partout sur
notre territoire et pour pas lier aux
défillances de l'État les collectivités
territoriales non'ont d'autre choix que
de trouver des solutions sur leurs
moyens propres et je tiens d'ailleurs à
les saluer tous nos qui se démène au
quotidien pour apporter une réponse à
nos concitoyens je salue ainsi ma région
la région occitanique qui a créé depuis
près de 2 ans des centres de santé avec
des équipes et avec des médecins
salariés qu'ell finance elles-même sans
compensation de l'État la France trahit
ainsi le pacte social hérité du Conseil
National de la Résistance et sa promesse
d'égal accès aux soins et nous le savons
les inégalités ne cessent de s'accroître
et ne cesseront de se creuser si nous ne
prenons pas des mesures structurelles
fortes face à des esppérances de nos
concitoyens dont nous sommes tous
témoins sur nos territoires le
gouvernement fait la sour d'oreille ne
semble toujours pas prendre la mesure du
naufrage de notre système de santé nous
sommes aujourd'hui face à un véritable
abandon n'ayant pas peur des mots de la
santé par ce gouvernement nous sommes
donc réunis pour aujourd'hui examiner
aujourd'hui une nouvelle proposition de
loi un peu four tout de la majorité
gouvernementale et comme pour la PPL ris
2 examen de cette proposition de loi
arrive au beau milieu des négociations
conventionnelles avec les médecins une
fois de plus la la temporalité et la
méthode
interroge certaines mesures représentent
néanmoins un progrès et nous les
soutiendrons ainsi nous saluons
l'interdiction du cumule d'exonération
fiscal et d'aide à l'installation
qu'elle soit proposé par les
collectivités territoriales ou les
agences régionales de santé et ce afin
de lutter contre le nomadisme médical
nous défendrons égal ement la
possibilité de signer dès la deè année
du premer cycle un contrat d'engagement
de service public le CSP et son
élargissement aux étudiants en maotique
et en pharmacie cette mesure prévoit
vous le savez qu'en comprepartie d'une
allocation mensuelle les futurs médecins
s'engagent à exercer au minimum 2 ans
dans un désir médical à la fin de leurs
études enfin nous soutiendrons la
création d'un statut d'infirmiers
référent pour les patients en affection
de longue durée que nous élargirons
d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble des assurés
qui le son souite cependant nous
déplorons que les articles les plus
réformateurs de cette PPL a été
supprimés en commission ainsi nous
proposerons de rétablir l'obligation de
participer à la PDSA pour les médecins
libéraux et selon des modalités fixées
contractuellement avec l'agence rale de
santé depuis 2002 et la loi mattiti
n'existe plus d'obligation de garde pour
les médecins libéraux elle est basée
uniquement sur le volontariat et nous
observons depuis une dégradation de la
permanence des soins 38 % seulement des
médecins pratique cette permanence des
soins et ce sont bien sûr toujours les
mêmes et ceux qui travaillent déjà
beaucoup et qui sont souvent en burnout
ce manque de garde de la part de la
médecine libérale a pour effet direct un
engorgement des urgences et qui se
retrouve bien sûr par voie de
conséquence dè lors en grande difficulté
une autre mesure que nous souhaiterions
réintroduire dans ce texte c'est l'anné
de professionnalisation obligatoire dans
les déserts médicaux pour les médecins
généralistes 4e année de profilalisation
qui face à la peine de médecin
permettrait de déployer rapidement 4000
étudiants chaque année dans les zones
soudansces enfin nous souhaitons mettre
au débat la création d'un nouvel
indicateur qui a été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui dressera une
cartographie précise par bassin de vie
de la répartition de l'offre de soins
sur le territoire français cet
indicateur aura pour objet de définir
dans les zones les moins dotées un
niveau minimal d'ovre de soins à
atteindre pour chaque spécialité
médicale il devra pour se faire tenir
compte des besoins de la population et
du temps réel médical conventionnel donc
sans dépassement d'honoraire disponible
sur chaque territoire et ainsi que la
sociologie en particulier le nombre de
personnes âgées de ce territoire et
pourrait être donc un véritable outil
dans l'élaboration de nos politiques de
santé mais outre ces mesures certaines
questions pourtant majeures ne sont pas
évoquées dans cette PPL en effet pas un
mot sur la problématique de
l'attractivité de la médecine
générale ni sur la form des médecins les
mesures coercitives vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre les coercitives pur
n'ont pas de sens ni d'efficacité si
nous ne repensons pas la formation et
l'organisation de l'exercice de la
médecine en France ces leviers sont
fondamentaux pour mettre fin à la
situation de pénurie et pour lutter
contre laertification que nous
connaissons pour aller plus loin nous
allons proposer aussi à cette assemblée
de voter pour la mise en place d'une
organisation coordonnée du parcours de
soins de premier recours que nous avions
proposé l'année dernière dans notre PPL
et qui est préconisé même par l'Ordre
national des médecins face à la pénurie
il est en effet primordial de faciliter
le gain de de temps médical et une
organisation de soins coordonnés centré
sur la répartition des actes entre le
médecin traitant et les autres
professionnels de santé au travers d'un
protocole du établi par une équipe
permettra de dégager du temps médical et
en priorité pour les patients sans
médecin traitant ou en al cette mesure
répond ainsi à l'objectif de faciliter
la prise en charge des Français par une
équipe de soins primairire de proximité
qui est le but rechercher de plus nous
proposons de mettre en place une mesure
pour encadrer l'intérim médical et
paramédical puisque depuis le début des
années 2000 le recours au contrat
d'intérim à l'hôpital a augmenté de
manière exponentielle et son coût annuel
qui était de 500 millions d'euros en
2013 est passé à 1,4 million d'euros en
2018 face au développement de ce
véritable mercenariat médical les gardes
pouvaient être rémunérés vous le savez
jusqu'à 2500 € la loi riste 1 a
effectivement prévu de limiter la
rémunération de de ces gardes et c'est
très bien mais nous proposons une mesure
complémentaire qui est celle de limiter
dans la durée en nombre de jours par an
la possibilité d'exercer en intérim
notre but n'est pas d'interdire la
possibilité et notamment pour les jeunes
de recourir à des contrats de courte
durée il s'agit d'encadrer l'intérime au
sens strict c'està-dire que la mise à
disposition du praticien se fait par le
biais d'un contrat passé avec une
entreprise d'intérim enfin et nous
l'avons déjà évoqué les politiques
incitatives mises en place notamment par
les collectivités territoriales n'ont
pas fonctionné et bien au contraire
elles ont parfois entraîné des effets
pervers de concurrence entre les
territoires ou de surenchè de la part
des médecins face à cet échec de la et
au regarde la situation de pénurie nous
est apparu nécessaire de mettre en place
une mesure de régulation à
l'installation des médecins libéraux le
conventionnement sélectif qui prévoit
que dans les zones dans lesquelles il
existe un excédent en matière d'offre de
soins je vous rappelle que c'est 3 % du
territoire un nouveau médecin libéral ne
peut s'installer en étant conventionné
assurance maladie que si un médecin
libéral de la même zone cesse son
activité cette mesure visa à rétablir un
équilibre dans l'installation des
médecins sur notre territoire nous le
savons et nous en sommes d'accord il n'y
a pas de remède mir
ou de mesur magique mais il faut une
volonté politique et je sais que nous
sommes nombreux dans cet hémicycle à
avoir cette volonté désormais monsieur
le ministre il y a urgence il est temps
d'agir et d'entendre la détresse de nos
concitoyens face au problèmes des
déserts médicaux je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame pouirol la parole est à
Monsieur califé califé pour le groupe
les républicains pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission Mesdames
et Messieurs chers collègues je me
réjouissz de voir l'intérêt porté aux
mesures qui visent à améliorer l'accès
aux soins mais j'avoue qu'à la lecture
de cette proposition de loi j'ai trouvé
que la que la montagne accouché d'une
souris durant ma longue carrière de
médecin hospitalier j'ai assisté aux
difficultés croissantes de notre système
de santé qui ont conduit aujourd'hui au
désarroi des usagers et des acteurs de
soins agir rapidement à travers une
nouvelle loi et bien sûr nécessaire mais
ne confondons pas urgenence et
précipitation
entre avancé mineures et mesures
contraignant ce texte n'est clairement
pas à la hauteur du défi qu'il s'était
posé de ce fait les médecins libéraux
sont-ils prêts à l'accepter alors même
que la reprise des négociations euh
conventionnelles n'ont pas encore
débutter les les professionnels
hospitaliers particulièrement désespérés
sont-ils prêts à y adhérer malgré des
idées judicieuses ce texte demeure à
amas de mesurettes incapable de redonner
à notre système de soins les outils
nécessaires pour accomplir sa mission
sans rentrer dans les détails
j'évoquerai trois points majeurs et je
commencerai par le Conseil territorial
de santé que pour lequel je cherche
depuis 2016 une place et une efficacité
le faire passer d'un rôle consultatif à
un rôle plus exécutif nécessite d'autres
leviers et surtout une certaine
indépendance c'est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui et le texte n'en donne pas
les garanties suffisantes pour l'accès
au soins si certaines mesures proposées
trouvent un intérêt ell restent
conditionné par la démographie des les
soignants que le texte évite d'aborder
clairement les professionnels non
médicaux et pour ce qui les concerne les
régions se sont adapté pour assurer les
besoins et surtout la répartition
territoriale des instituts de formation
en revanche il revient à l'état monsieur
le ministre d'adapter la grille
salariale aux qualifications demandées
cette proposition de loi n'y fait pas
allusion quant aux professionnels
médicaux mis à part quelques
dispositions de portée limité nous
n'avons pas non plus trouvé de
propositions qui visent à évaluer
notamment les études médicales que ça
soit la passelace ou les concours
d'internat et les rapprocher de
l'aménagement du territoire cher à nous
tous nous déplorons aussi que cette
situation a donné lieu au développement
d'une autre médecine totalement éloignée
des règles bonne de Bonn pratique
clinique et de la pertinence des
soins Mesdames et Messieurs les déserts
médicaux inquiètent nos concitoyens et
préoccupent les collectivités qui
essayent bien que mal d'y faire face
avec force et conviction mais il revient
à l'État dont c'est la compétence
d'activer en priorité tous les leviers
nécessaires le projet proposé n'y fait
aucune allésion et c'est regrettable
enfin en ce qui concerne la permanence
des soins il est rassurant et
satisfaisant de constater que les
urgences vitales ou graves ne souffre en
France d'aucun dysfonctionnement et que
leur prise en charge est assurée avec
professionnalisme par les services
adaptés par contre il est urgent de
revoir la prise en charge des situations
dites urgence ressenti nous aurions aimé
voir apparaître dans le texte quelques
solutions telles que la généralisation
des consultations de médecine générale
au côté des services d'urgenence que le
rôle du médecin urgentiste soit recentré
et il faut réappliquer davantage les
services hospitaliers en aval des
urgences afin de fludifier le parcours
des patients pour conclure je ne peux
que regretter que que la santé soit
constitué un domaine réservé à une
politique de petit pas et que ce texte
ne réponde pas aux problématiques de
fond tellement nécessaire à notre grand
malade j'appelle donc de tous mes vœux
une grande loi cadre qui permettrait
enfin de redonner au monde médical la
sérénité suffisante pour accomplir sa
mission je vous remercie merci Monsieur
califé la parole est à Monsieur
Christopher zourk pour le groupe des
nonincrits pour 3 minutes monsieur
zourk madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je crains que ce texte soit
l'occasion de se donner bonne conscience
en évitant soigneusement le grand
chantier des politiques de santé que
mérite nos compatriotes la pandémie du
covid-19 a été pour ceux qui nient
l'évidence un dramatique révélateur
celui du champ de ruine qui était devenu
le système de santé français des
personnels hospitaliers au bout du
rouleau une faiblesse générale des
moyens une médecine de ville qui s'épuis
une désertification qui loin de
concerner aujourd'hui uniquement nos
campagnes commence à gagner nos villes
moyennes et une dépendance
pharmaceutique et matériel qui a empêché
toute réactivité lorsque le covid est
apparu la question de la désertification
médicale et des territoires carenc
nétait pas nouvelle il faut tout de même
le rappeler et la quasi totalité de
l'échitier politique a géré le pays et a
constaté la chute sans jamais vraiment
l'avoir Igué les conséquences sont
fatalement dramatiques avec des
personnes qui abandonnent leur parcours
de soins par fatigue ou par lcitude qui
voi des opérations sans cesse retardées
ou des retards de diagnostic avec une
prise en charge bien plus difficile de
ce fait de certaines pathologies et un
moindre taux de réussite des soins
malheureusement la désertification
médicale tente à se généraliser et nous
craignons le grand nombre de départs en
retraite de généralistes et de
spécialistes mais aussi de
professionnels du paramédical jusqu'en
zone urbaines et pé urbaine dans les
années à venir aujourd'hui la question
n'est donc plus de savoir où sont les
déserts médicaux mais où où ils ne sont
pas et tout cela crrédite fatalement le
sentiment de déclassement français
autant de problématiques auxquelles
chers collègues ce texte ne répond pas
mes chers collègues c'est toute notre
notre politique de santé publique qu'il
faut remettre à plat ce texte élu de la
question de la formation massive de
nouveaux médecins du recrutement
difficile d'infirmiers et d'ê soignant
la question globale de la gouvernance et
de l'échec des agences régionales de
santé aucune mesure d' tion ou
d'incitation des professionnels à
exercer dans les territoires carencés
urbains comme ruraux excusez-moi d'être
trivial mais cette proposition de loi
est une rustine sur un bateau qui prend
l'eau de toutes parts bref un côter sur
jambe de bois un acte de bonne
conscience mais Guer plus et je suis à
peu près sûr que fondamentalement nous
sommes une majorité à le penser ici tout
ban confondu pour autant presque rien
c'est toujours mieux que rien du tout
alors nous nous abstiendrons mes chers
collègues il y a urgené vous le savez le
pas de vague ne doit pas être généralisé
à l'offre de S que mérite no
compatriotes alors il faut sans mauvais
Jun mot ruer dans les brancards je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Zurek la parole
est désormais à Monsieur Daniel Chassin
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues 93 % des Français
placent la santé au premier rang de
leurs préoccupation alors que plus de 6
millions d'entre eux n'ont pas de
médecin traitant il est donc nécessaire
d'améliorer l'accès au soins de nos
concitoyens et notamment la prise en
charge des soins non programmés je
rappelle qu'actuellement il y a plus de
médecins tisés qu'en 1990
malheureusement beaucoup d'entre eux ne
souhaitent pas installer ou préfère être
salarié faut poursuivre donc monsieur le
ministre l'augmentation de la formation
ce texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
est su d'une proposition du député
Frédéric Valtou qui vise à apporter des
mesures pragmatiques pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins de nos compatriotes en
misant notamment sur l'échelon
local l'article 1er renforce l'action
des conseils territoriaux de santé avec
comme objectif un meilleur accès aux
soins il fait des des cts l'échelon
central de l'organisation locale de la
politique de santé donnant ainsi une
place primordiale aux professionnels de
santé du territoire nous regrettons que
la liste précisant la composition des
cts ait été supprimée car elle
permettait d'assurer une représentation
exhausive de l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire nous soutenons le dispositif
prévu article 2 bis qui permet de lutter
contre le nomadisme médical en limitant
à une fois tous les 10 ans les aides et
exonération fiscal lié à l'installation
de même que la suppression de la
majoration du ticket modérateur pour les
patients dont le médecin a récemment
quitté son cabinet cela évite très
justement une double peine nous
approuvons également l'élargissement du
contrat d'engagement de services public
aux étudiants du premier cycle ainsi que
l'engagement l'intérim des
professionnels de santé l'encadrement
pardon sur ce point nous partageons la
version adaptée en commission le
réhaussement à 60 15 ans article 2
quierme de l'âge jusqu'auquel le cumul
emploi retraite est possible pour les
médecins est également une mesure de bon
sens je connais des hôpitaux qui
n'auraient pas pu fonctionner sans ces
médecins cet
été nous regrettons la suppression
article 2 ter de la PPL du sénateur
Danny wbet qui permettait la mise à
disposition pendant 3 mois contre
remboursement d'un fonctionnaire auprès
d'un médecin s'installant dans un désert
médical ce dispositif aurait représenter
une véritable aide pour un médecin
arrivant dans un territoire qu'il ne
connaît pas je soutiendrai donc tous les
amendements réétablissant cet article à
titre personnel je regrette également la
suppression de l'adhésion automatique
des professionnels au CPTs article 3 qui
permettrait une meilleure coopération
entre tous dans la prise en charge des
soins cette mesure n'aurait pas été
contraignante puisque elle s'accompagne
d'un droit de retrait j'ai déposé un
amendement pour le rétablir nous
soutenons évidemment le rééquilibrage de
la permanence des soins en établissant
en établissement de santé proposé dans
l'article 4 mais je pense qu'il existe
aussi un sujet tout aussi important
concernant la permanence des soins
ambulatoires de jours la prise en charge
des soins non programmés est
organisé de de nuit 20h à 8h et les
dimanches les ou ferriers mais je
constate qu'entre 8h et 20h certains
besoins sont non programmés ne sont pas
satisfaits il est donc impératif pour
moi de renforcer la permanence des soins
obulatoires et j'ai déposé un amendement
visant à ce que les maisons de santé et
les cabinets médicaux membres d'une CPTs
s'organis pour assurer à tour de rôle la
charge effective des soins ambulatoires
non programmés c'est par le renforcement
des il faut renforcer les cts afin que
il y ait moins de malades qui arrivent
aux urgences je ne suis pas favorable à
la tion d'un infirmier référent qui
créerait une confusion avec le médecin
référent sauf avis du médecin traitant
mais ce dernier doit conserver la
compétence du diagnostic et de
l'orientation nous
approuvons
l'augmentation du délai avant l'action
en dissolution d'une sisa portant une
maison de santé mais lorsqu'il ne reste
qu'un seul médecin je regrette que mon
amendement permettant leur création à
partir d'un seul médecin et n'est été
jugé
irrecevable nous soutenons enfin les
articles facilitant l'exercice des
praticiens diplômés hors Union
Européenne pas du dont notamment la
proposition d'une attestation d'exercice
provisoire qui serait attribué après une
commission nous pensons que une
commission régionale pourrait suffire
composé de professionnels de santé et
des représentants de l'ordre compétent
par parce qu'il contient plusieurs
mesures pragmatiques de bon sens et axè
sur les territoires notre groupe
soutiendra l'esprit de ce texte je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Chassin la
parole est désormais à Madame Joseline
guidz du groupe Union centriste pour 4
minutes chers
[Applaudissements]
collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues je tiens d'abord à remercier
Madame Corine Ambert rapporteur de ce
texte au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales pour son travail
consencieux et de seul sa s'il a été
difficile cette proposition de loi qui
nous est soumise à l'examen aujourd'hui
vise à améliorer l'accès aux soins par
l'engagement territorial des
professionnel répondre aux inégalités
territoriales encourager la coordination
entre ville et hôpital entre libéraux et
salariés tout en impliquant les élus
locaux figurent parmi les objectifs de
ce texte cependant il se présente comme
un ensemble disparate de mesures
insuffisantes touchant à l'organisation
des soins de ville aux études de santé
et à l'hôpital faute d'un projet de loi
structurant en matière de santé tant
attendu chers collègues cette
proposition de loi s'inscrit en effet
dans la lignée de plusieurs autres
initiatives parlementaires toutefois
vous l'aurez compris ces actions
hétérogènes extrêmement dispersées dé
pourvu vue de cohérence d'ensemble
présente un impact limité sur la crise
actuelle de notre système de soins en
ville comme à l'hôpital c'est comme
poser un pansement sur une jambe de bois
d'autant plus que l'inscription à
l'ordre du jour de ces textes avec un
calendrier politique déraisonnable voire
brutal suscite des interrogations sur la
pertinence du traitement de ce sujet au
combien important pour les Français la
méthodologie adopté ressemble à un
trompelœil par conséquent nous soutenons
les amendements de suppression de la
commission qui porte par par exemple sur
la mesure qui entend automatiser
l'adhésion des professionnels de santé
au CPTs la mesure qui prévoit d'ouvrir à
certains cabinets et maison de santé la
mise à disposition de fonctionnaires
l'idée déjà rejetée au Sénat en mars
dernier la mesure qui propose de créer
un indicateur territorial de l'offre de
soins de nombreuses données statistiques
existent qui permettent de documenter
les inégalités d'accès au soins la
mesure qui prétend rétablir pour les
professionnels l'obligation de
participer à la permanence des soins
ambulatoire celui-ci revient sur des
dispositions votées à l'occasion de la
proposition de loi de Madame ris sur
l'accès aux soins et qui n'ont pas
encore produit tous leur effets si l'on
peut reprocher à ce texte un manque de
vision d'ensemble et des mesures de
faible portée comme des évolutions
décevantes pour les conseils
territoriaux de santé certaines
dispositions sensiblement enrichies par
les travaux de la commission nous
semblent de bon sens augmenté à 75 ans
l'âge limite pour les médecins exerçant
en cumule emploi retraite en
établissement public de santé ou dans un
centre de santé géré par une
collectivité territoriale prévoir un
préavis de 3 mois pour les médecins
chirurgiens dentistes et sag-femmes
cessant leur activité pour lutter contre
le nomadisme qui n'est le fait que d'une
minorité des professionnels de santé
lever certains freins dans la gestion
des sociétés interprofessionnelles de
soins ambulatoires qui abritent la
plupart des maisons de santé
pluprofessionnel supprimer la majoration
du ticket modérateur et des tarifs des
spécialistes hospitaliers pour les
assurer dont le médecin traitant a pris
sa retraite ou déménager lors des 12
derniers mois les sénateurs du groupe
Union centriste sont également favorable
à l'intégration des professionnels de la
médecine scolaire dans les CPTs ainsi
que la création de fonctions
d'infirmierers référent chargé d'une
mission de prévention et de suivi le
texte comprend aussi une réforme
substantielle du régime applicable au
praticiens à diplôme hors Union
Européenne pas du visant à assouplir les
conditions d'autorisation d'
et améliorer l'attractivité de la
procédure ces dispositions contribuent à
répondre aux besoins de recrutement des
hôpitaux enfin notre message est clair
ces efforts ne sont malheureusement pas
à la hauteur des attentes en dépit de
ces remarques et espérant qu'elles
seront entendues le groupe Union centrce
soutiendra cette proposition de loi
visiblement enrichie par les travaux de
la commission je vous remercie pour
votre écoute merci Madame GUID la parole
est désormais à Monsieur Olivier du
groupe RDPI pour 3 minutes 30
[Applaudissements]
secondes madame la Présidente Monsieur
le le ministre monsieur le Président de
la Commission madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues c'est la première fois
que je m'exprime au sein de cette
assemblée et j'y porterai avec notre
collègue Nathalie Goulet les aspirations
du département de l'Orne rural qui
connaît comme d'autres une situation
dramatique concernant l'accès aux soins
de sa population alors que la moyenne
nationale est de 149 médecins
généralistes pour 100000 habitants nous
nous pouvons compter dans l'ordre que
sur 60 généralistes pour 100000
habitants c'est-à-dire que concrètement
il faudrait quasiment doubler le nombre
de généralistes ornés juste pour
atteindre la moyenne nationale par
ailleurs 43 % de nos médecins ont plus
de 60 ans le pire est donc devant nous
alors que nous avons déjà aujourd'hui 20
% de nos assurés sociaux qui sont sans
médecins traitants si la situation
hornaise est particulièrement grave
malgré l'engagement fort des
collectivités locales elle correspond à
ce que vivent certains autres
territoires cependant les disparités
territoriales sont énormes et il est
trompeur d'affirmer que grosso modo 87 %
du territoire serait un désert médical
on agglomère ainsi des situations qui
sont peu comparables dans leur intensité
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
regrette que dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi que nous que nous
examinons notre Commission soit revenue
sur la création d'un indicateur
territorial de l'offre de soins qui est
aujourd'hui l'outil statistique qui nous
manque pour objectiver ces disparités
territoriales avec une méthodologie
indiscutable la connaissance précise et
partagée de la situation est le
préalable à l'affirmation d'une
politique encore plus ambitieuse
l'engagement n'a pas manqué ces
dernières années suppression du numérus
closus recrutement de médecins salariés
d'assistants médicaux création et
développement des CPTs développement de
la télésanté soutien au centes de santé
pluri professionnel mesures incitativ à
l'installation bientôt le déploiement
des médicobus et des délégations de
tâche pourtant il va falloir aller plus
loin pour faire face à l'aggravation à
venir de nos difficultés et la
proposition de loi examiné apporte des
points positifs il faut les prendre sans
attendre je formule toutefois le vœux
que nous puissions aussi débattre
prochainement à nouveau de la question
de la régulation de l'installation des
médecins une régulation concertée avec
les professionnel concernés avec un
accord donnant donnant car nous
préférons toujours la négociation à la
coerition si les négociations avec les
médecins n'aboutissent pas n'ayons pas
peur par contre de passer à une méthode
plus directive observons ce qui a été
possible de faire avec les kiné les
infirmiers plus récemment avec les
chirurgiens dentistes avec les deux
principaux syndicats qui ont signé avec
la CNAM une convention le 21 juillet
dernier parmi les mesures adoptées par
les partis le noncentionnement des
dentistes par l'assurance maladie des
dentistes qui s'installent dans des dans
des zones jugées non prioritaires
évidemment qu'une telle mesure appliquée
au médecin ne réglerait pas toutes les
difficultés de loin pas il n en aurait
d'autres à adopter qui seraiit tout
aussi utile mais face à la gravité de la
situation qui s'annonce tous les tous
les leviers vont devoir effectivement
être actionnés je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur bit la
parole est désormais notre collègue
Patricia Deass pour le groupe les
républicains pour 3
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi en
discussion aujourd'hui n'a pas
l'ambition ni même l'objet de régler par
des mesures fortes le manque de médecin
et le problème prégant des déserts
médicaux auxquel comme beaucoup d'autres
mon département des Alpes Maritimes est
confronté je pense aux communes rurales
qui m'ont saisie au travail herculéen
des maires de RO estéron de puugéénier
de Guillaume et de bien d'autres édiles
encore qui se démènent partout en France
pour trouver un médecin et obtenir
désespérément comme dans les cas
d'espèces qui ont été les miens une
autorisation d'exercice à des médecins
étrangers volontaires pour s'installer
en zone Soudans il y a ici utilité de se
pencher sur les circuits de validation
des diplômes étrangers certainement
perfectible mais assurément trop long et
surtout opaque au m force de constater
que le CNG a un silence particulièrement
difficile à comprendre trop souvent les
candidats découragés abandonnent ce qui
est bien malheureux pour les populations
privées d'accès à un médecin généraliste
et il est à regretter l'absence dans ce
texte de solutions véritablement
satisfaisante j'en viens à présent à la
création de la fonction d'infirmier
référent qui est une mesure favorable à
l'amélioration de notre système de santé
encore que les contours n'en soient pas
définis notre rapporteur Corine ber dont
je salue le travail et les propositions
a d'ailleurs souhaité y apporter un
encadrement législatif en réservant ce
dispositif au malade en al il sera de
toute façon besoin de texte
d'application je tenais ici à rendre
hommage aux infirmiers ces
professionnels de santé dont la présence
et les fonctions sont d'autant plus
précieuses dans les territoires ruraux
où la désertification médicale est
combiné avec le vieillissement de la
population et je me demandais monsieur
le ministre s'il ne serait pas
souhaitable à minima de commencer par
revoir le décret de compétence des
infirmiers en date du 29 juillet 2004
rester en l'état depuis bientôt 20 ans
malgré plusieurs réformes du système de
santé intervenu depuis lors et pour ne
citer qu'elle la crise de la covid qui a
confirmé leur rôle crucial dans le
dispositif sanitaire d'ailleurs comme
vous me l' indiqué dans une réponse à
une question que je vous avais posée
l'évolution du cadre d'exercice de cette
profession est nécessa
alors Monsieur le Ministre Jose quand
donc ce décret sera-t-il enfin actualisé
j'ajoute pour finir ne pas comprendre
pourquoi les professionnels de santé
libéraux qui sont là pour paliier les
manques justement de cette
désertification médicale ne sont pas
tous soumis au même régime d'indemnité
kilométrique pour leur déplacement la
simple équité s'impose s'impose
d'aligner le montant de cette indemnité
déconnecté de l'acte lui-même et rien ne
justifie objectivement l'écart constaté
creusé en plus par l'augmentation du
prix du carburant alors monsieur le
ministre je vous invite à ne pas oublier
de consolider l'existant celui qui
contribue à assurer les sons au
quotidien des Français dans tous nos
territoires je vous remercie merci
Madame Deass la parole est désormais à
madame Béatrice goselin pour le groupe
les républicains et pour 3
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre nous le savons tous
les crises successives ont bouleversé et
mis à l'épreuve les fondements du
système de santé français si celui-ci a
tenu le choc des vagues épidémiques à
répétition les symptômes de ces
dysfonctionnements sont de plus en plus
vifs au premier rang desquels une
désertification médicale qui inquiète
nos concitoyens
87 % du territoire national fait partie
de ce que l'on appelle le désert médical
la France a perdu 5000 médecins
généraliste entre 2010 et 2021 alors
qu'elle gagnait 200
habitants pour remplacer un médecin il
faut désormais deux ou trois médecins en
raison du vieillissement de la
population des avancées sociales contre
la SEM comme la semaine de 35h de la
féminisation de la profession ou du
rapport de la parentalité au travail
c'est le constat est sans appel sur le
manque de praticien de la santé nous
devons prendre garde à ce que remède ne
soit pas pire que le mal certaines
mesures pourraient avoir des
conséquences encore plus graves sur
l'attractivité des métiers du soin nous
ne pouvons pas nous permettre une
augmentation de la du
déconventionnement toute mesure
coercitive ne réglera pas le déficit de
praticien c'est pourquoi nous devons
faire émerger des mesures nouvelles
solides et pérennes afin de renforcer
l'accès aux soins en premier lieu il
faut impérativement revaloriser les
rémunérations des professionnels de
santé nous devons également favoriser
davantage la coopération entre eux pour
dégager du temps médical je pense ici
aux communautés professionnelles
territoriales de santé CPTs comme celui
du sudmanche celui du territoire de
Grandville et
Villedieu cette cette communauté a
permis d'accompagner ses praticiens au
développement de et à la coordination de
l'offre de soins de santé sur ce
territoire cependant nous constatons que
ces professionnels de santé sont tribut
c'est nous constatons pardon que ces
CPTs sont tributaires de l'engagement
des professionnels de santé et figé le
CPTs dans la loi n'apporterait rien de
plus accompagnons les structures
d'exercices coordonnées et soutenons le
recrutement d'assistants médicaux les
médecins libéraux doivent pouvoir être
de vrais employeurs à la tête de leur
cabinet je regrette d'ailleurs que nous
ne tou ne sachions pas reconnaître ni
valoriser davantage les compétences
spécialisées de certains infirmiers en
pratique avancé qui apporte beaucoup à
la prise en charge des patients je tiens
à saluer les dispositions prises par
notre rapporteur pour le suivi des
patients de longue durée par ses
IPA la Manche est engagée pour le la
désertification médicale ce département
finance s idées novatrices au service de
la santé des Français mais ce n'est
toujours pas suffisant certaines
collectivités salarient des médecins
d'autres mettent à disposition des
cabinets médicaux et des logements
attention cependant aux effets de bord
pour palier à une offre de soins
insuffisante dans des territoires la RS
a identifié des zones Soudans en médecin
mais celles-ci peuvent créer des
distorsions entre communes voisines
ainsi une municipalité de la Manche
ayant investi dans une maison médicale
se voit concurrencer par une
collectivité voisine bénéficiant de ce
zonage mais l'État ne doit pas compter
uniquement sur ces initiativ local il
doit prendre toute sa responsabilité
dans ce combat et s'approprier les Maes
Hippocrates rétablir préserver et
promouvoir la santé je vous remercie
merci Madame Gosselin la parole est
enfin à Monsieur François bonhomme du
groupe les républicains pour 3 minutes
Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
Bonhomme
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues vous
conviendrez que la question qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui ne nous surprendra
pas cette proposition de loi est un
nouvel avatar d'une cascade de loi et de
plans gouvernementaux sur la question de
l'accès aux soins dans nos territoires
qu'il s'agisse de la loi HPST de la loi
Forcade de la des pactes territoir santé
la loi Touren le plan mass santé 2022 la
loi séure ou encore les différentes lois
de la sécurité sociale la question de
l'accès aux soins pour nous pour tous
constitue et continue de se poser avec
une acuité particulière bien sûr il a eu
des dispositifs à saluer notamment le
développement des MSP les nouveau
dispositif pour inciter l'installation
des jeunes praticiens de santé ou encore
le déploiement d'assistants médicaux de
même la médecine étinérante ou encore le
recours à la télémédecine pourtant
malgré ses avancées la désertification
médicale n'est pas enrayée et parfois
progresse autrefois quand on est dans
les zones rurales reculé elle s'attaque
aujourd'hui aux villes et même aux
grandes métropoles que l'on croyait
préserver de ce phénomène nous en
connaissons les causes la combinaison de
viissement de la population nécessitant
une prise en charge sanitaire de plus en
plus fréquente et un renouvellement
insuffisant et mal réparti sur le
territoire d'une nouvelle génération de
médecins généralistes mais aussi de
spécialistes rappelons que le nombre de
médecins généralistes à activité
régulière en 2022 a diminué de 11 %
depuis 2010 soit 10128 médecins en moins
en 12 ans c'est donc un corps médical
vieillissant et une pratique de la
médecine quant à elle en pleine mutation
disons-le clairement il est à craintre
que ce nouveau texte ne réponde que de
manière très technocratique à ces défis
qui mettent à mal l'accès au soins et si
l'esprit qui anime ce texte va dans le
bon sens c'est-à-dire celui de mieux
rationaliser l'action des acteurs locaux
de santé pour l'heure les multiples
structures
ght CPTs ESP esesss MSP centre de santé
sans pile au final nous voilà avec une
organisation qui est
lisible difficilement lisible plutôt
tant pour les patients que pour les
acteurs l'objectif de constituer de
véritbles bassins territoriaux de santé
est certes louable il s'agit aussi
d'impliquer dans cette chaîne le maillon
des élus locaux ainsi la gouvernance
locale autour des cts risque de ne pas
disposer des moyens de leurs ambitions
l'état l'ét l'état souhaitant garder le
contrôle via l'ARS et le préfet c'est ce
qu'à souligner fort justement la
commission des affaires sociales qui
note qu'il ne confie aucun moyen
d'action nouveau au cts avec un risque
de bureaucratiser un peu plus la
médecine libérale insuffisamment
associée en ce qui concerne un plus
grand recours Pasu c'est un phénomène
qui simplifie vous le savez mais si
faire appel à des compétences
extérieures est une bonne chose en soit
il convien n à moins de ne pas er sur la
qualité et les savoirs professionnels
chers collègues finalement ce texte
comme beaucoup d'autres est décevant et
ne répondra malheureusement pas ce défi
majeur qui se pose pour nous pour
refonder notre système de santé et
favoriser l'accès aux soins pour
tous merci Monsieur
Bonhomme monsieur le ministre vous
voulez la parole je vous la donne
volontiers merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs le les sénateurs
juste je voudrais revenir sur sur
quelques points sans refaire le le débat
je je voudrais d'abord dire que je crois
profondément à la dynamique qui est qui
est à l'œuvre et qui est à l'œuvre dans
tous les territoires je suis frappé à la
fois d'entendre à la tribune beaucoup
s'émouvoir à juste titre de la situation
et dans les discussions ou sur les
territoires chacun de pouvoir témoigner
d'une expérience de maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle de CPTs
avec la coopération avec des pharmaciens
des infirmiers des médecins je trouve
pour ma part sans aucune forme de dénis
sur la situation et et la seule lecture
du courrier qui arrive tous les jours au
ministère de la Santé fait fait une
corde de rappel assez solide mais si je
prends l'exemple madame la sénatrice
pomirol en en Occitanie aujourd'hui euh
je considère par exemple pour ma part
que le lien entre l'ARS et la région sur
des tas de projets est extrêmement euh
extrêmement important il y a pas d'un
côté je dois dire je salue évidemment
les maires j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
dans ma dans ma déclaration je salue
aussi les les les fonctionnaires de
l'État ou des collectivités qui se
bagarre pour pour trouver pour trouver
des médecins et pour faire avancer les
dossiers dans les mots que que que que
j'ai du mal à à entendre je je j'ai vécu
et beaucoup d'entre vous ici ont vécu au
premier au premier rend la crise du
covid c'est l'idée que le covid aurait
misise en lumière un champ de ruine nos
soignants notre pays il a tenu il est
aujourd'hui celui un de celuis dans
lesquels la mortalité a été la plus
faible à la différence de de la plupart
des dictatures accessoirement la
démocratie a fonctionné notre système a
tenu au prix de l'héroïsme de soignants
au prix de la mort de certains soignant
y compris au prix de de de de du
dépassement de soi de de beaucoup de
gens mais non je ne peux pas enfin je ne
peux pas je je vous laisse évidemment la
responsabilité de vos propos mais c'est
au nom même de la bataille que l'on mène
pour redonner de la force à ce système
de santé que je ne peux pas laisser
adosser le mot de champ de ruine à ce à
ce qu'il est ce système il est à la fois
et vous sans doute le vivez-vous chaque
jour dans votre vie ou celle de vos
proches il est à la fois formidable
parce qu'on est soigné formidablement
dans ce pays et extrêmement fragile
toujours sur le bord du précipice et ce
texte il est un de ceux qui essaie de
contribuer à l'éloigné du précipice je
ne dis pas qu'à lui seul il est il est
suffisant juste deux dernières remarques
madame la Présidente si vous le
permettez il y a toujours et j'ai
entendu beaucoup de de demandes de de
faire une grande loi sur la santé alors
évidemment la la la première la première
intuition quand on devient ministre
c'est c'est évidemment le le narcissisme
et de celle de se dire Ettien si j'étais
si j'étais le nouveau claudvin en
associant mon nom à une loi définitive
euh mais moi je vais je vais vous dire
quelques quelques chiffres depuis 2019
le PLFSS dans sa son volet assurance
maladie a progressé de 50 milliards
d'euros 50 milliards d'euros en plus le
PLFSS 2021 c'est celui qui met en place
le financement des mesures annoncées
dans le séur je ne crois pas qu'il ait
recueilli l'approbation sur tous les
bandes de ce de ce texte le pfss de l'an
dernier c'est celui qui met en place
l'expérimentation sur la cystite et et
l'angine notamment pour les trodes dans
les dans les pharmacies que dans
quelques jours où vous aurez à dont vous
aurez à connaître pour permettre aux
pharmaciens de de suppl dans le partage
des tâches avec les médecins euh ce ce
sujet-là le PLFSS de cette année c'est
celui qui proposera d'augmenter de 25 %
le travail de nuit des professionnels
non médicaux dans les hôpitaux et
contraire contrairement à ce qui a été
dit le PLFSS de cette année il sera bien
évidemment supérieur à l'inflation et
supérieur de 8 milliards d'euros à celui
de l'an dernier c'est-à-dire la
bagatelle du du budget du ministère de
la Justice ce sont donc des mesures
concrètes sur la nuit parce que et je
finis par là je ne veux qu'il n'y ait
pas de doute notre bataille quotidienne
et notamment sur ces mesures
d'attractivité c'est celle qui
permettent de recruter de fidéliser de
rouvrir des lits d'offrir plus de soins
et cette bataille on la partage
avec les régions je l'ai cité sur les is
vous avez à juste titre madame évoqué le
rôle essentiel des infirmières oui nous
sommes en train de retravailler ce
décret le décret de compétence nous
sommes aussi nous allons aussi rouvrir
une négociation conventionnelle avec les
pharmaciens et les les pharmaciennes et
donc je pense que c'est une approche
globale encore une fois ce texte n'est
pas une cathédrale mais je pense que
beaucoup des cathédrales que l'on a
constru depuis des DESC en matière de
santé ont parfois été un peu plus un peu
un peu plus décevantes que certaines
mesures concrètes et dont une bonne
partie vous les retrouverez dans le
PLFSS et j'imagine qu'il y aura une
évidente cohérence entre vos appels à la
mobilisation de beaucoup plus de moyens
et évidemment le vote sur ce dernier
texte merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
la discussion générale est donc
désormais close nous allons passer à la
discussion du texte de la commission je
suis saisie sur l'article 1 d'une
demande de parole de monsieur le
Président Philippe
Mouillet merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
quelques mots avant d'atacacer l'examen
des articles et des amendements de cette
proposition de loi sur un sujet
important que que sont notamment les
ordonnances